Patty and I,
my coauthor and I were,
were struck,
we had written one book before called womenomics,
which was essentially a look at women in the workplace.
And I hope a lot of you know this data because it's really compelling,
but there's all this data about the more women there are at the top of
companies,
the more money a company makes.
And just really,
really interesting case for diversity that's not based on doing things because
it's right.
It's really just because it makes business sense.
So that's what we were writing about.
But we were doing all these interviews with women who were incredibly
successful,
probably like a lot of you in this room and we and certainly looked successful
to us and confident and they would say things too.
It's like,
well,
I'm about to get a promotion but I don't think I'm qualified or my bosses want
me to try this.
I don't know that I'm ready and it,
or even talk about feeling like an imposter,
which was something we all are familiar with.
But we were so struck by that because we,
I think Katee and I both have felt frequently that we're not confident or
failures or [inaudible] but we thought what about this is crazy,
these women are so successful.
And so we started digging into that,
um,
to see whether there was data behind it and essentially we found there is a lot
of data to support the notion that there's a confidence gap between men and
women,
especially at work.
Right?
Not as much in our social lives or in our family lives or lives with friends.
And we started to try to look at why that is.
I mean,
one of the,
um,
one of the best pieces of data that I like is this corporate poll that was done.
The showed that women will apply for a job or a promotion when we feel we have,
what percentage would you imagine of the qualifications?
Yeah,
100.
I heard 100 and I don't think 110 was an option because definitely we would want
110 and men will take the risk at about 60% and of course that,
uh,
what we found over time is that attitude.
It's not just about applying for jobs or permissions,
it's about,
is this report ready?
Am I going to participate in this meeting?
Am I going to do this?
Am I going to do that?
And women are constantly judging themselves,
not quite ready or not quite prepared.
And in fact,
men tend to swing the opposite way.
It's so interesting.
Columbia University has studied this proclivity on the part of men too,
to kind of,
um,
be overconfident or overconfident about their performance,
right?
And taking a test,
let's say,
and they found on average,
men are overconfident or overestimate their abilities by about 30%.
But what's interesting about that too,
as they call that honest overconfidence,
right?
So it's not,
I think for a lot of years I thought that's just bravado,
right?
These men are just faking it.
They can't fit.
They're not faking it.
Right?
They really do have that.
I see that with my son.
They have that ability to assess themselves differently.
And I think what we ultimately found is that that at work confidence actually
matters in terms of success.
There's a professor who's been studying this out at Berkeley,
confidence versus competence and he's found that in many cases confidence trumps
competence in terms of being valuable for traditional success,
which we found sort of appalling.
But um,
but we realize this is a skill women need to build.
That's absolute,
I think a lot of us can relate to that.
And we've actually done some internal studies here and um,
one of the things,
I think maybe you even wrote about this,
about this project where,
and some of you might be familiar with this at Google,
where women had to put there,
women weren't putting themselves forward for promotions and our engineering
teams.
And so somebody recognized that women weren't getting promoted.
So they started to send out emails to say,
you know,
you put yourself forward.
And once the women were getting nudged to,
okay,
I'm going to try.
Then they recognize that they could put themselves forward and the numbers shot
up,
but they weren't seeing women put themselves forward.
I think we've come a long way since that original study.
But I thought that,
I think we've really talked about that.
You know what I think I,
I've Kinda ever,
if we put it in our book or,
yeah,
we're certainly,
I talk about that a lot,
but I think it's,
I think a lot of us can relate to that.
So as you started to look into that,
then you wrote the confidence code.
Um,
and then do you want to just talk a little bit about how that evolved and
thinking about people coming up to you about their children and with,
so we,
um,
we wrote the confidence code,
which really seemed to strike a chord with a lot of women.
And,
and the other thing I will say about confidence,
just so we all understand the formula,
because in the,
in the book for adults,
we got a little obsessive about the science,
the biology,
the May,
you know,
where does it come from?
How do we get it to men have a confidence gene that women don't have.
You know,
we were sort of all of these questions about origin questions and men don't in
fact have a confidence g and that we don't have,
which is nice to know.
Uh,
but,
but confidence is partly genetic,
which we thought was really weird.
Uh,
and we tested our genes for the genes they know about now to see whether,
uh,
you know,
we had them,
we don't,
Katee and I are both basket cases in terms of confidence jeans,
but,
um,
but it's only partly genetic,
right?
And the bulk of our confidence we build throughout the course of our lives.
And this is so important for women,
right?
So confidence isn't about feeling good or feeling that were valuable or how we
feel about ourselves.
Confidence heavily involves action.
So confidence is what turns our thoughts into action and what we,
and that's important because I think we often get stuck in the thought,
the thinking part of that.
And we say,
oh no,
I'm gonna think can overthink that and not act.
But what we also found is the creation of competence.
It's really a virtuous circle.
You build more confidence when you take that risk and you act and maybe you
fail,
maybe you struggle,
maybe you work through the process,
but you master something.
That's the way you build more confidence.
So when women don't act,
they're not stockpiling more confidence.
Right?
So that,
that we thought was pretty critical.
And what we,
we realized this happening with girls is,
um,
and we got pretty obsessed also with girls and young women cause we're like,
Gosh,
they excel at school.
They just beat the pants off boys right now at school rate.
It's really people who are worried about education thing or worry more about
boys than girls.
So like how does that,
why or why are young women still not confident?
Um,
and what we realized is happening,
and Carol Dweck who wrote the great book mindset people might hear,
might be familiar with that explained to us that it just,
if life were one long grade school,
girls would rule the world,
right?
But,
but it's not.
And the standards change appreciably once we're out in the real world.
And so what happens with girls is we become perfectionists,
right?
We are so good early on because of the different ways our brains works are
higher Eeq at pleasing people,
coloring within the lines,
getting everything right,
doing everything.
And parents and teachers encourage that.
And by the time girls are in high school and middle school today,
I mean it's worse than ever.
I mean full blown people pleasing,
perfectionist.
And if you're a perfectionist,
what do you not want to do?
But that's way too scary to take risks.
If you're a perfectionist,
right?
You want to stay in your lane,
do what you're already good at.
And so boys still from an early age,
and forgive me because you'll see that this is a positive as I'm talking about
you men in the room.
I mean,
they fail all over the place,
typically from an early age,
right?
They just do it more naturally and they learn it doesn't matter that much.
Right?
Which is a powerful lesson to learn.
Girls aren't really learning that as much.
And then you hit the workplace and that's what you need to be able to do is take
risks and fail.
It's almost as though somebody changed,
you know,
we educate girls in this system and then it's like,
oh,
and by the way,
we're going to require something completely different of you right now.
So we,
and,
and what we found in some of a little bit of the data we had was that,
um,
the,
the drop for confidence for girls seems to happen about puberty.
And between that and then what we would hear from parents who were talking to us
a lot as we would give speeches about,
you know,
yeah,
this is all great for me,
but what can I do for my daughter?
You know,
I see this is crazy.
What's going on with my daughter?
Uh,
we just thought we wanted to dive in and really take a harder look at what's
happening with girls and see if we could just help a bit.
And are there some practical things and all of us can think about who first of
all,
who are parents and how we conduct ourselves at home and how we react to things
that happen in our own lives.
You have some tips on that?
Yes.
So if you've,
um,
so if you think about what you most want your daughters to do and it's hard to
do because our,
remember,
I mean the,
the,
all of this pressure about school and grades and you know,
it's all out there,
right?
But you do want your kids to build resilience and confidence while they're still
at home with you.
And that necessarily involves struggle and failure.
So I think the heart,
the most important thing,
and it's,
it's actually kind of liberating as a parent because you can suddenly say,
Oh,
is your child is striking out the fifth time in a row at Bat?
Or whatever it is.
And you think,
oh my God,
this is horrible.
This is,
and you have realized,
actually,
if I can help him through this,
this is going to be a great life experience.
So I would say that the,
the overarching tip is look for ways you can encourage your daughters to step
outside of their comfort zones and do things they're really not good at and get
comfortable being uncomfortable.
And that's going to be different for every girl,
right?
I mean,
my daughters loves athletics.
She's a tomboy.
I thought when we started working on this,
I thought,
oh well that won't be,
della shall be immune to this stuff because she's kind of sporty.
She's still a perfectionist and I'm never going to try out for the debate team.
I'm too scared or I don't want to stand on the stage to do this.
And you know,
it's just so you'll have to look for opportunities where you can say,
try it.
The result doesn't matter.
Really kind of give,
you know,
make them feel they have a safe environment.
But look for areas where they might be able to do things where failure's okay
and they see that they can work through it.
And do you think about how you might react to things that happen in your work
day and talk about that?
Well,
so I think for mothers,
especially,
the most important thing we can do is be good role models.
And I mean,
especially for all of you,
cause it's too late for me.
I screwed up and it's like all over,
but please,
it's not too late for you.
Um,
but it,
when you,
we want a model that we struggle too and that we have failures and we have
things that are hard to deal with and have those discussions with them and say,
you know,
oh my editor who's here.
Oh,
I remember distinctly talking to Dell at one point saying,
oh,
I got notes back from my editor.
I'm not going to want to go through them.
There are things she does not like or you know,
I'm going to have to really deal with this.
And then at night sort of having her listen and talk through well,
but that's okay.
I think overall she likes the book and,
um,
some of these changes are going to make sense.
And I kind of opened them up to some of that stuff that we deal with.
That's hard.
I mean,
we sort of don't,
it's not our natural inclination to want to do that,
but if they see that their parent is trying all the time to be perfect and that,
then that's really not,
um,
that's not great role modeling for them.
And I would also say with,
so we did a lot of,
um,
polling for this book because there we wanted more data and we did find in fact
that,
um,
girls experience between the ages of eight and 14,
a 30% drop in confidence,
right?
That really big up until age eight,
it's girls and boys have the same confidence measures.
But the,
the other thing we found is that fathers are better at recognizing a lack of
confidence in their daughters than mothers are.
So I think dads can actually play a really important role because it does,
this behavior does look so weird to them typically.
Right?
It's like,
what do you mean you're scared to do this?
It just doesn't make sense.
Whereas I think we don't like it,
but we also,
there's part of us that understands it.
Oh yeah.
I know why you wouldn't want to get up on stage.
Totally.
You know,
or just so I think fathers can,
um,
that's a good can do a lot too.
And then you also looked at social media.
Yes,
we did look at social media.
Um,
you know,
look,
we,
we tried to be realistic about it because kids kind of live on social media
right now and for girls.
Um,
I'm going to take a step back and say the other thing that happens besides a
confidence dropped for girls,
and this is related,
is that at puberty,
this instinct to ruminate or overthink kicks in.
And that is something that we all really probably experiences women where you,
you get that review and you think about the one area of improvement and not the
rest of it,
which was great for two weeks straight.
And you're years or years,
maybe years,
as Jen pointed out,
she still remembers that trip to that failure in Moscow.
It's like we're right there center.
Um,
but this starts for girls at puberty.
And I really was struck by that because I thought,
oh my gosh,
they have no,
like what must that feel like?
What your brain is being hijacked,
right?
And you don't really understand what's happening and why you can't stop thinking
about something.
Well,
what social media does the psychologist talk to us about for girls is it just
exacerbates that,
right?
So it's like ruminating on steroids,
You,
you 1520 years ago you might've been able to go home,
have a fight,
have a fight with a friend,
get a bad grade,
or whatever it is,
and you're forced to put that aside at least for a couple hours or overnight.
That just doesn't happen anymore.
It just keeps going and going in.
It's amplified.
So we,
our goal in the book is to help girls understand that,
understand that there are ways you can put it down that are realistic,
not just never use social media,
right?
Because it's just not something that's going to happen.
But I think also just as importantly,
how do you use it in a positive way?
Because there are really powerful ways for girls to use it right at this age.
There's this desire to connect to find people who are like them.
Girls are very open at that age too.
Um,
you know,
inspirational advice,
uh,
inspirational,
saying,
seeing role models,
people they really admire and how they think about things.
So I think we tried to offer a lot of suggestions about how they can find their
tribe that way and really focus on that in a positive way.
And you did a campaign with Instagram.
We did.
We did a great campaign with Instagram called,
um,
now I'm going to blank.
I can't believe we did an amazing campaign with Instagram,
which was true,
which was girls showing there.
Basically it was how do you basically showing your confidence,
capture confidence,
but,
um,
show yourself doing something that makes you feel confident.
Don't show yourself,
um,
looking photo shopped or perfect or having the perfect life or something where
you're going to get a million likes.
Show yourself doing something right.
So we have a big focus on action in the book,
but that makes you feel confident.
And we just had a bunch of incredible girls who helped us with that,
who are very,
um,
out of the box girls and we had a great reaction to it.
I'm curious,
um,
the timing of this book,
oops.
I think with the me too movement,
I'm just curious if you have thoughts sort of on this whole good girl.
Don't rock the boat the way a lot of us were raised and in light of what we're
seeing with me too,
which you thought about that.
Yes,
we will.
We were,
me too was exploding as we were finishing the book again is our editor here will
remember and we,
we thought about how do we talk about this for eight to 12 year old girls,
right?
Because it's not straight forward,
but,
but it is true that I think what we realized is if girl girls are absolutely
essential to creating a speak up culture.
And I think one of the biggest risks,
right?
If we all agree that confidence involves taking some risks,
one of the biggest risks for them is speaking up in a way that might mean people
don't like them or they're not pleasing the person they want to please.
And so we,
um,
we created a manifesto in the book,
which really has to do with,
um,
my favorite part of it.
There are three or four bullet points is it's not my job to please people.
And I think for girls to understand that is not their primary function,
right?
To constantly be the person who's going to be liked or that adults are going to
think is wonder.
You know,
they need to learn a little bit of um,
uh,
bravery on that front if you will.
And I think once they,
once they feel confident about speaking up,
uh,
I think that will be a big boost for the next generation in the workplace.
We,
oh yeah.
Well we definitely want to take questions.
So there's there,
if you guys could nine apples,
it will require confidence to then move to the mic and ask that question.
So do you have any other tips in the book that you,
that come to mind about language or,
I also a social media,
just the whole idea of just put down the phone for a little while.
He's like that.
I think that just seems too obvious.
Sort of have the off 24 hour rule,
right?
Which is the cool off rule we have that kind of,
you can write something but don't send it right away.
Wait a day before you send it,
which I still need to actually employ sometimes.
Um,
I think,
you know,
one of my favorite rules really is to,
uh,
we,
we call it,
I guess we,
it's not released get out of your comfort zone.
I guess it's,
it's really the rule of,
um,
almost taking it,
giving yourself a timeout,
which is when you have something scary happened to you or you've are processing
a failure and you're starting to ruminate and everything.
And this is the same for adults as well as kids.
You have to get your brain away from that for a little bit.
Right?
You literally can't process anything when your fear center or you're a Mig.
Dilla is on high alert.
So we talk about changing the channel and essentially that means,
you know,
watch a TV show,
take a run,
eat some ice cream,
kind of let yourself get to a different place,
read a book and then you can get back in and look at things.
But I think especially for girls to understand,
I have some control over what's happening inside and here's how,
so we have kind of a,
a series of steps like that that I think will be clear for parents too.
Yes.
I was curious to know,
you were talking about like some data,
some data and pulling that you had done.
I was wondering if there was a difference in communities of color because there
has to be some disparities when,
especially with parents not thinking they're afforded the privilege of,
you know,
making sure that their kids make mistakes that often.
I was just curious to see what that looked like.
You know,
we did,
um,
in the polling we did with girls,
we didn't,
we did not see a big breakdown in terms of race or ethnicity in terms of girls
confidence in the polling.
We did,
we did,
uh,
confidence pole or a confidence quiz after our adult book came out where we
women went online and a lot of women went online and took this quiz.
And,
um,
we found that African American women were more confident generally than white
women who are more confident than Asian women.
Right?
Who that but are the professors who helped us with this and to pursue that and
kind of dig into why that is.
We'd need a larger sample size and we'd want to do additional polling,
which we didn't do.
But I do think there's,
um,
there's no question that if you look at,
all of the data on something called stereotype threat,
right?
When you are,
when you feel different.
So like you're one of the only women on a board.
You're one of the only women at a meeting.
You're,
what are the only African American women in a me,
you know,
that there are degrees of different might feel that really does affect your
confidence and your performance.
So I think the more things you have in your life that make you feel other from a
larger population,
it's,
it is a real,
and,
and I think it's important for girls and women to understand that,
you know,
it's,
um,
it really does have an effect,
right?
So it's not all you,
right.
It's partly the society.
And I think understanding that also allows all of us to give ourselves a break
to some extent.
But,
um,
we have a lot in the book on,
uh,
you know,
girls who feel different for a variety of reasons,
whether it's race,
whether it's their religion,
whether it's being transgender or whether it's,
you know,
and so we,
because that you're absolutely right.
I think that's,
that's an extra burden to try and to be fully confident and it's,
it's riskier and a lot of ways.
Yes.
Hi.
Um,
I have a one year old daughter,
rose and rose has two daddies.
And,
uh,
you mentioned that fathers have an important role to play and kind of
recognizing a lack of confidence situation.
Um,
but I also heard you say that mother is kind of maybe have more empathy or more
understanding of how a girl might feel.
And I was wondering other than surrounding her with strong female role models,
um,
do you have any tips or anecdotes about ways to essentially bridge that empathy
gap?
No.
And I should say,
and I usually say this at the beginning of every speech,
like so we are all on a spectrum,
right?
So not every woman is going to be more empathetic.
Not every man is going to be more narrow focus.
Not every one was.
So when I talk in generalities,
because generally speaking,
most things are often true,
but it doesn't mean that men or can it be empathetic.
I mean there's really interesting data also that shows that men who,
um,
men who are the primary caregivers and spend an enormous amount of time around
their children actually do experience hormonal changes and really did a real
difference in sort of the e Q factor.
So I think a lot of it probably has to do with proximity to some extent.
Um,
but I don't think,
uh,
I think that chess helping girls understand that they can be heard is important.
And,
and I think again,
you're right about the role models.
Let them see people who are like them.
Um,
but not so,
you know,
one psychologist said to us,
and this is why we in the book,
we have some real girls at the end of each chapter who've done some amazing
things,
but we specifically chose not to focus on a lot of girls like say Malala or you
know,
girls who are just extraordinary,
right?
But who probably are going to seem far away from what most girls the way they
might think about themselves.
So I think trying to find role models who are accessible for them and who've
done things that are
similar,
but,
but it just seems within reach somehow.
But I don't,
I,
my sense is you're not going to have,
you know,
if you're paying attention to your daughter,
I don't think you're going to have an empathy problem.
I wouldn't worry about that.
I'm wondering if you can talk a little bit about internal versus external
confidence.
Because I know within myself and um,
my friend circles,
we definitely show ourselves very differently than how we're feeling.
I just started working here.
This is my second week and
that's competent.
Thank you.
Um,
the fake it till you make it message came to me from a lot of different people,
specifically women.
And I'm wondering why we have to fake it if we are here in this room and feel
and feel like we don't fully belong until we have to fake that we belong.
No,
we have a section in our adult book on the does fake it till you make it work.
And our conclusion was,
you know,
maybe sometimes,
but it's actually not the best advice.
So I will counter what you have heard from other people and sit because first of
all,
women or are saddled already with constantly feeling like we're frauds and
imposters and faking it.
And so just adding another layer onto that and saying,
okay,
now I'm going to be someone else again.
And,
um,
but I think what fake it till you make it get set is that,
that if you think back to that,
you know,
formula for confidence,
right?
What often,
what needs to happen is,
is you have to take that first risk,
right?
You have to just get some experience under your belt.
You have to,
and how do you do that?
How do you get over that chasm?
And I think it's far better to tell yourself to recognize that you're afraid or
you're nervous to understand that that's normal.
It would actually be odd not to be,
right?
So that's a completely valid feeling.
And then just tell yourself what,
I'm just going to do it afraid this is a afraid somebody gave you a switch.
It's just acknowledge you're afraid but choose to act anyway.
Right?
It's and,
and,
and I also think that,
I don't,
I don't work here so I don't fully know the culture.
But what I've seen as I speak in a variety of different corporate settings now
is it's,
it's so different than it was even five years ago or 10 years ago.
I think people are open to more honest conversations about how you're feeling,
what are your struggles?
I'm nervous.
I'm not,
I've got my kids.
I'm worried about this.
I mean,
I remember there was a woman who was a mentor for me at ABC who at one point
said,
well,
but part of the problem is,
you know,
you this other person,
she,
she doesn't talk about her kids and you,
you made me just have to not do that.
And I looked through,
I said,
I,
I'm literally in capable of doing that.
I can't do that.
I just kind of talk about this stuff all the time.
And I,
and I think we're,
we're past that point where you have to pretend to be something.
I think it's all right to be vulnerable,
let people in and you can still be extremely competent and successful and
actually probably relate to people a little bit better.
Yeah.
Be More authentic.
We actually did a presentation at Tgi off of a couple of years ago where we
talked about imposter syndrome and the company and something like 95% of all
Googlers experience it.
So,
you know,
a lot of us are feeling the same thing.
I don't belong here.
And uh,
right,
right.
It's pretty common,
especially I'm sure at a company like Google where it's just got this kind of
name and you,
you know,
you think,
wow,
what am I,
why am I here?
You know?
And,
um,
but the,
I would say led authenticity,
Trump,
this sort of feeling of trying to be something you're not good and
congratulations on the job.
Yes.
Um,
I'm sorry,
I just wanted to comment on,
on just the previous question.
Uh,
I got a good lesson from,
from someone in my past when I was faced with a difficult decision that kind of
said it helped me know,
uh,
try to isolate the reasons why you're not doing something.
And if you're left with fear,
then that's not a good enough reason.
So that's great.
So that's just,
and,
and like,
I agree with what was said here.
You in very good company,
if you're feeling it that you don't belong and you can feel pretty safe about
talking to people about it because,
um,
so in,
you know,
a very common sentiment in,
in lectures like this [inaudible] talked about books like this is a,
you know,
we have,
I think a fair amount of young parents here.
And our main concern,
especially as parents of girls is,
you know,
how do we make the next generation better?
Like you said,
we're already kind of screwed.
You know,
we,
we suffered a lot of society's influence,
uh,
which is I think the biggest factor in,
in,
in confidence among women.
Um,
and I wanted to ask,
you know,
so right now my oldest daughter is only three and a half.
I feel like I have a fair amount of influence on her.
I know that once she enters the school system,
the amount of influence I have,
well,
we'll go down and I want to ask what's next for you?
What,
when are we going to see the confidence code for schools,
uh,
and the confidence code for parents.
Uh,
do you have any thoughts in that direction?
Well,
you know,
we're hoping that,
um,
I,
I think that,
you know,
we are working on a curriculum for schools so that they could use this book and,
um,
and for girls,
especially in middle school,
I think it's for parents.
I think you'll find when you look at it,
it's really self explanatory in terms of following along with,
because it's very much workbook,
like it's full of quizzes and tests.
And I was telling Jen that some grown women have said,
I actually liked this book better than your adult book because of hero.
It's red,
it's got the list.
And it's much it.
So I think we hope for parents that will be,
um,
fairly easy.
But it is,
that is just one of those I,
yeah,
it's really hard to see your kids face all these other influences.
But I,
I again,
I think you have to as a parent realize,
um,
that,
that the more you can get out of the way and let them experience things and
experience problems and issues and failures and encouraged them through that,
you know,
the better off they're going to be soon.
Sooner rather than later because it's like you want him to have him while you're
around and yes,
you're there to,
you don't want to wait for all of that stuff to happen.
Well I think that's a good point,
right?
The more you can help your daughter and you know,
before she hits Middle School,
get used to doing some failing,
you're,
I like to think of it that you're,
you're going to inoculate her because there,
I mean like middle school isn't really not fun.
It's still not fun,
you know,
it really isn't and you can't control what friends are going to do and the way
teachers are going to treat you.
And so the more you can do early on to,
to let her fail and build up some resilience,
it's great.
I mean,
I will say the other thing is,
and it's not for everybody,
but there's incredible data that shows that,
um,
you know,
athletics for girls makes a huge difference.
I mean,
there's almost a direct link between the longer a girl plays a sport and the
higher ranked she reaches in the workplace.
I,
I of course did no sports,
so I was like,
oh darn.
But,
but,
and I don't think it's only about athletics,
it's just that athletics creates this.
Um,
it's,
it's really a ready made forum in which girls can lose and fail over and over
again.
And they have no choice.
Right.
They just have to get out there and do it.
And that might be also a debate team or trying out for a play or it's just a,
it's just the,
you know,
the athletics,
they're there and you don't have to think about it as much.
But thank you for your question.
Um,
so just a little back story.
I was raised by a single mom and she worked in finance pretty much my entire
life and she was often one of the only women in a situation.
And she's a very confident woman.
And in turn I've been raised to be very confident.
But in then I have definitely in time has been called a bitch.
I've been called domineering.
I've been told that I'm pushy.
And um,
how do you basically teach girls that it's okay to be confident without intern
receiving that kind of feedback?
You know,
one thing I say,
especially honestly to young women,
and I think with girls,
it's important to start early with that conversation.
But I think I,
I really love talking to young women today because there's so much more focused
on all of these issues than I ever was.
Right?
And they ask a lot of questions,
but,
but there's also still this sense of like,
I want to navigate things perfectly,
right?
How can I avoid these issues?
So to some extent you'd won't totally avoid it,
right?
You,
and I think what we as women have to understand as there have to be a number of
women who are willing to be labeled pushy or a bitch or whatever it is,
so that we can finally broaden the,
the,
this box of behavior that women have been kind of confined in.
So,
um,
so I try to encourage people to kind of gird for that battle a little bit and
realize,
okay,
yeah,
this is bad for you,
but it's really good for everybody else what you're doing.
Um,
but,
um,
but I do think for,
again,
this piece for girls,
if the earlier we can help them understand that they don't need to worry about
being liked all of the time.
I mean,
I had,
I remember seeing a therapist once told me,
I,
I was really worried about some work issue.
And I said,
I'm worried,
I'm going to seem really mean.
And he's like,
Claire,
I don't even know what you could do in order to sound,
you know,
just,
and I think for most of us we can,
you know,
we're,
the world is not going to hate women,
right?
We're not in danger of heading over to that dark side.
So I think that the,
the more we can encourage girls to understand,
they don't have to have everybody pleased all the time,
it will become more normal.
Right.
You're straight forward.
I'm sure I'm ambitious leading leadership like behavior will be viewed that way.
Right.
Instead of why while she's pushy.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
but thank you for doing that.
Um,
so I have a nine year old daughter and she's been exhibiting a little bit more
like less fear of doing something at school that she would fail out,
but fear of like physical things like an elevator or like going over a bridge or
something like that.
And did you notice that?
Is that,
is that part of this for young girls?
You know,
I think it's,
I think what it tends to happen at puberty is that there's this,
um,
uh,
and,
and forgive me for like doctors or scientists in the room because I'm really
short handing this,
but what happens with our brands and with the influx of estrogen as we're just
even so much more aware,
right?
There's this hyper awareness that happens of people's expressions,
what we see,
you know,
around the room,
what we,
what it might feel like to realize,
oh wait,
I'm in the elevator.
Like we're just this,
this like puberty is really um,
an exceptional period that way.
So it's not uncommon and I've heard other people talk about that and I think a
lot of what a lot of the tips we have in the book are heavily based on cognitive
behavioral therapy because essentially the,
you know,
the way to get comfortable taking risks is really to create different thinking
habits,
right?
Habits and the way we think essentially.
And that's cognitive behavioral therapy.
And so a lot of the steps in here in terms of acclimating yourself to risk
taking I think would be really helpful,
right?
You sort of go through this process like what's the worst thing that's going to
happen?
Then you do step two and then you do step three and you can almost even create a
ladder of things and that,
and it makes a difference.
What's really helpful for parents by the way too,
is to have this
broad view over time that your kids will not have an,
actually,
it's really hard for me to have,
I have for barely any memory anymore,
but if you can literally think back and say,
Oh,
do you remember six months ago how you were afraid to do x and look at what
you've done now and sometimes ties some of those things together.
That's really,
really powerful.
How's it being here?
So I'm curious,
it seems as degree have a lot of these conversations we talk about how to
provide women with traits that are traditionally more male,
masculine.
And I'm wondering whether you and the course of your research,
it's how the other side of that people talking about tips for boys,
for men and then generally it's is my point of view.
Like we're not having that conversation as much and you don't see bucks in the
child's about that and why that is.
Maybe.
And if you think we should have that conversation too.
You know,
I do think,
honestly,
especially in the wake of me too,
I think we could use a book for boys.
I could use one instead of having these really awkward conversations with my 16
year old son about,
you know,
well wait,
what are we?
Wouldn't you think you're going to kiss her weight?
Well,
you know,
I'm like talking about all this.
It's real.
I'm like I need a buck.
Um,
and I,
but I,
I think,
I think the two things,
so,
um,
ideally we're not saying in urging women to think about whether they're
confident or not or girls be more like men.
And so we try to be very explicit about that actually in both books.
I think.
I think it's really important for girls to feel as confident as they are
competent.
Right?
So we got on to this issue with the scientist who studies and confidence in
rats,
it cold spring harbor.
I didn't know they were confident and non-competent rats,
but there are,
but what was so,
cause we really wanted to drill down on the idea of,
okay,
what is the perfect amount of confidence to have if we assume women tend to
underestimate them,
their abilities,
men tend to overestimate what do you really want?
And he said ideally to make great decisions in life,
you want your confidence in line as in line with your competence as possible.
Right?
Because that is useful.
But actually it's useful to have a teeny bit more confidence because that pushes
you to do things.
That's the kind of boost you get for doing.
So I think that,
um,
I,
I think confidence,
the trick for,
for women and men and gender and everything is that confidence can be expressed
in a lot of different ways.
So we're not really talking about mad men style behavior,
right?
Like,
Oh,
I'm going to be the first one in the room and the loudest one at the meeting and
the person telling everybody wrote what to do.
And,
uh,
that doesn't have to be your style of confidence.
That's not really even confidence,
right?
That's just behavior.
And it is behavior.
We've come to accept this confident behavior because generally speaking,
that's the kind of behavior exhibited by the people who created the workplace.
Right?
And so,
so there is something to the effect that the workplace was created and you know,
uh,
with men and mind,
I think that the norms will benefit from a big change.
And I think that that is a conversation that has to,
that has to come from the top down,
right?
Because that's really a conversation about what does a leader look like.
Are we really being inclusive about everybody's leadership qualities?
Are we recognizing that leadership qualities?
You know,
women bring very different skills to the table,
but we will never bring those skills to the table if we're not willing to say I
deserve a promotion.
Right?
So to me,
that's not a male or female asset.
That's actually just a,
I recognize that I'm qualified and competent.
Um,
but that was a really long answer.
The short answer is we need more books on boys.
And I think it would be really useful because I think boys and [inaudible] is,
is critical,
right?
Boys need to kind of have a,
um,
a lot more of those skills that girls and women have.
And I think everybody would be happier.
And I think when you were talking about bringing your whole self to work and not
being afraid to talk about what's going on with your family,
I think that those are some of the things that everybody can learn from.
Yes.
Yeah,
exactly.
Speaking of boys and men,
hold on.
It was exactly what I wanted to ask actually.
I have a girl and a boy and I think my girls will definitely enjoy the book,
but I can't show it to my blog.
So yeah,
if you flip the,
at least was called the confidence code,
VA could give it.
Right?
Right.
But do you think that,
um,
is your boy,
do you feel like he's confident or
in some way or is he is,
but I,
I see so many new things where he's afraid to take the risk and you could
benefit from it.
Yes.
Well,
I think you should read the book and it will definitely help you with both
chapters because I have one of each and it was super helpful.
So yeah,
I think there is a,
there would,
it is huge.
I mean,
look,
we're,
I've had a lot of men come up and say,
look,
we're all,
we all overthink,
we're all scared of risks.
We're all,
you know,
we feel this way too.
And of course men feel this way.
I think the biggest differences that men typically don't go on to be
perfectionist,
right,
who'd be spent a lot of wasted time on things when they could.
And also I've had a couple men say,
you know,
I get scared,
I get nervous,
I don't want to take the risk,
but I,
but I act any way.
But there's still this propensity,
this push to act that,
um,
men often have.
And that then results in learning.
But it's,
I think,
again,
we're,
you know,
talk to that woman right there and
we're looking,
you know,
for a book for boys thinking about that.
Thank you.
I thank you.
I have a seventh grader,
a girl,
and I think what you said really resonated when she was young.
She was fearless unless you ran for class president and lost a boy.
But she was like Gung Ho.
But now she's changed.
I mean I think she definitely,
maybe her pure group of girls are like really into looks really to beauty.
She's like,
where are,
you know,
looking at the mirror all the time,
shop looking for shopping stuff.
So I feel like her,
her peer group now,
it's kind of like influencing her away from being fearless,
like trying new things.
And he advised and she's sought on for all the time,
like iPhone all the time,
talking to friends,
chatting.
So any tips about how to steer her away from a pure group of other girls who may
be also like not exhibiting and confidence and just focusing on looks
it,
you know,
it's hard because especially when they get to be that age,
right?
They do their,
their friends mattered to them so much more than their parents.
And almost everything we say a suspect,
right?
I mean,
I can't,
you know,
my 13 year old daughter is just really,
really difficult.
She's not going to be watching this.
This is going to be awful.
But she,
um,
I think that what you can do as a parent is talk a lot about the things that are
valuable.
The fact that it's okay to stand out,
right?
It's okay to be different.
Look for people who might be interesting role models for her and who are
exhibiting some of this breaking out of the pack behavior,
right?
Or a focus less on,
you know,
we really try in the book to get into this focusing or don't focus as much on
what you look like,
focus on what you're doing,
right.
Judge yourself by what you're doing.
Um,
and for girls,
I think that's very powerful.
But for you as the parent,
you have to find the rate messenger because you're probably not the right
messenger.
So you have to be really subtle about it.
I mean,
and maybe the book is something to use and talk about that maybe,
you know,
there are a lot of great things,
great things on Youtube.
They're greet,
sort of inspirational channels.
People have created that.
Talk a lot about failure rate and being fearless for girls.
The other thing that you can really,
I think at middle school girls hooked on is get them mad about something and get
them to kind of feel this passionate about something,
whether it's animal welfare or the fact that their favorite sporting good store
doesn't stock women's basketball shoes,
which was Scott,
you know,
got my daughter in a rage and then tie that to what do you want to do about it,
right?
So if you can find ways where they get engaged in,
in,
in girls and women especially,
um,
have this drive often to be focused on issues that are bigger than themselves,
missions causes and they can feel more naturally confident diving into that
stuff.
So maybe for something like that you can get her engaged in.
Hello Matt.
Good luck.
I have a nine year old daughter as well.
And um,
in some ways a total risk taker.
I mean,
she's the first one to go off the zip line and the,
you know,
whatever.
She's super comfortable with risk in that way.
The piece that I find really interesting though,
sort of as a weird paradox to me is she's very,
very uncomfortable with being embarrassed in front of people.
And so she does play a sport as she played softball and just,
I mean,
just even last week she was destroyed because she didn't get a hit the whole
game.
And I tried to do the,
it's okay.
Even the best players,
even the pros don't get,
you know,
I mean all the usual stuff.
Right.
So I guess my question is,
you know,
is there a certain language is,
are certain ways to,
I mean,
God forbid I try to,
you know,
give the pep talk about failing and you didn't fail because you got up and you
bat and you tried and whatever.
Right.
It's not a fact that that really pisses them off.
That's like,
it makes it so much worse.
I mean total shutdown,
no conversation to the point where she wants to quit and doesn't want to play
again next weekend.
So I'm just wondering,
how do you,
you know,
is there a different language to use?
There is,
maybe it's a different time.
Don't say it in the moment.
I don't know.
I'm just wondering what's the right way in here?
Susceptive
not the world's biggest expert on sports conversations.
I found it incredibly painful with my kids.
I was like,
oh my God.
You know,
cause I felt like I internalized everything they're feeling and I feel at five
times more than they do.
So it's,
you know,
I'm not a great passive parent,
but what I've,
what I've see is that with this or anything else,
like you just have to think about your job as being as calm and unemotional
about it as possible.
The more emotional they are,
the less you are and it's really hard to do.
And you,
and you almost have to treat it like,
yeah.
Yeah.
That really was,
um,
yeah,
that will,
must not have felt good.
You know,
you kind of don't try to do the opposite.
Oh,
it'll be better next time,
but just say,
Yep,
I hear you.
And,
and in a lot of ways what we found talking to,
you know,
cognitive therapists and people,
you cannot process that she's not going to be able to,
she has to go through when kids are upset,
they have to go through that.
I'm really upset,
I'm grieving,
my fear center is firing and you need to think about how do I get her brain to
get out of that zone because when it's out of that zone later the next day,
she can then like,
oh look at this video and you can talk about,
you know,
this other softball player who failed a hundred times like a day or two later.
But in that moment,
the best thing to do is just that you want to lie in bed,
get some ice cream,
here's a book.
Well here's a movie.
Just kind of acknowledge it and try to help her through it and treat it like,
I mean the other thing I've seen with dads a lot more than,
because I don't,
and I'm not good at this,
but maybe they're,
they're great sports moms too,
is like just,
it's like you take it in stride rate,
it doesn't need to be over thought,
which again really hard for me cause I'm,
I'm an overthinker but I feel you don't let her quit.
Um,
you talked about overthinking,
we also talked about in your book about overpreparing and you talked about women
at night.
I definitely observed that when I was in TV that the women anchors would
overprepare and the men and I did research for both genders and I'm just,
I see that in the workplace here as well.
I'm just wondering what you saw in the research about the overpreparing and what
that was about.
You know,
overpreparing I find I can really relate to because that's I being a
perfectionist,
the people pleaser and over preparer.
You,
I realize now once we started studying confidence,
what,
what a waste of time that has been.
And I think that's what bugs me.
It's not that I didn't,
you know,
have a great job in journalism or I've,
yes,
I've written a book,
but it's just more like,
wow,
I,
I could have been doing even more and I wouldn't have been quite as stressed out
about it.
And I actually found,
I had somebody go back,
I don't know if I told you this story,
but I was so curious about the over preparation.
Cause I,
I spent a couple of years doing on,
um,
being the only woman on that political panel on George Stephanopoulos this show.
And,
um,
I thought I had,
I think the guys are speaking a lot more than I am.
And I always thought that every week I think they're going on longer.
I feel like I'm just cutting.
But I wasn't sure.
We went back and measured a year's worth of shows and I had talked 30% less and
I would constantly over prepared,
you know,
I would prepare this way and that way it just makes sure,
but then I didn't want to stray off of what I have prepared.
I felt like,
well,
no,
I know these things,
but I'm not going to jump in with an additional comment because I might not be
right.
And I,
you know,
and that's it's,
it's so limited.
As soon as you do the research after you,
or were you still on the show when you would do the research?
I did it as we were writing the book.
I got all the transcripts and I know it was really sort of surprising.
But Christine,
the guard said that to us too.
She said that she ducked catty.
That was a kind of shocking moment for us.
We had a great dinner with her.
She's an incredibly confident woman,
but she even said,
I think one of the ways I let confidence is I over prepare.
I never want to be caught off guard.
I prepare upside down and inside out and,
and Angela Merkel and I have talked about this a lot,
how we both overprepared carefully.
What,
okay,
so we're in good,
we're in good company,
but it doesn't mean it's a great use for experimenting with maybe just leaning
back a little and not doing that.
Definitely I create,
I created rules for myself about when I was still doing a lot more good morning
America,
which pieces were just,
okay,
this piece I'm going to spend two hours on,
I would,
I'd literally have to give myself a limit because especially working for good
morning America,
I could potentially work all night.
Right?
I literally could work all night on something and often wanted to,
but then I'd have my whole team working all night and people weren't that happy
and I was really tired the next day.
So I was,
I had to kind of create little rules.
We do that a lot in our office just to,
yeah,
yeah.
You just,
yes,
we could all work here all night and you will never finish all your work,
but at a certain point is it really worth it to keep doing that?
Um,
so I think we,
oh,
we have one more year will be our last question.
Okay.
So this might not be confidence for girls,
but I'm going to ask it anyway.
Um,
so my mother raised me to be very confident and more competent than she was as a
child.
Um,
so I was just wondering when you grow up that way and then you start being hyper
aware of like the lack of confidence other women are giving young girls or give
you are giving yourself after you like reflected.
I like now that you're older,
how do you go back and talk to the older women about it and their lack of
confidence and like how they are perpetuating that cycle.
Especially like your grandma or your mom and having that conversation with the
older women that were in your life without making them feel like,
oh you,
you mess me up.
Or anything like without being disrespectful.
And then also a second part to that is like seeing other young girls in your
family being raised that way and then trying to stop it but not disrespecting
their parents also.
So like I guess it's like a two part.
Yeah.
That is so tricky for,
we'll hand them the book.
I came a policy,
you don't have to take the blame.
Right.
I think it's right.
I think that is,
um,
that's one area,
especially with family members.
I say,
you know,
don't worry about being liked with family.
I think you still have to worry about being like dre because you don't want to
create a rift.
But I think it's maybe the way to do it is to just talk about the new roof,
new research that's out there.
And it's so interesting that in fact it's really important to encourage girls to
fail who knew,
you know,
and isn't this great and you know,
and,
and try to bring them along and make them see that it was their idea.
Because I think,
um,
it's,
it is hard to revisit parenting.
I'm really dreading this moment with my kids by the way,
right?
When they come to me and I'm like,
what did you do to me?
We tried our best.
But I think if you would start it as a discussion about,
I mean,
and that's one thing we've been really focused on in both of these books is
that,
you know,
there's a lot of data about this,
right?
We focused on the data and the science,
because I think for a lot of people,
although my,
my daughter's like,
if I hear you use the word research one more time,
I'm going to kill you.
Well,
some of your crazy research mom.
So,
but,
but you know,
most people will understand that,
um,
that there's meaning to it,
right.
If there's some science behind it and some data,
and I think that take the sting out of it.
It's not just a,
it's not just judgment,
but great question.
Sure.
Right.
Thank you so much.
[inaudible] a lot in the book is great.
I highly recommend it.
Thank you.
Pleasure.